all right JC what's up so close all
right
I know could you have done anything
differently to get to the final two
yeah winning competitions yeah that's
definitely what's gonna like bring me do
to you know like top two was winning
competition I know at the end gets crazy
with the trials and stuff so it was
literally winning competitions all I had
to do you know what you want a big
competition when I counted though yeah
they perfect the perfect ice I knew I
was I was gonna get out there forth and
I won just came at the right moment and
then I was just waiting for they only
want to come at that right moment but I
didn't so did you exceed your
expectations meet your expectations or
not get where you wanted to go I know
winning is where you wanted to go but of
course I mean of course I wanted to win
you know it was like having the Big
Brother 20-win entitled I'll be amazing
but I went there and I told myself I'm
gonna do it a loyal job I only have like
one loyalty and then you know I did my
like I did my job in like a bit
classiest way possible my lies trying to
know like like really like play too much
with people made it like feel like
playing stuff always in fun and labs and
stuff and I hope I didn't hurt any
feelings I'm pretty sure I didn't but um
but no I'm proud of the job I did I got
third place and I don't have anyone to
blame or myself it was just a matter of
the competition third place and winning
the last competition WAPA me myself in
top two and probably like winner I call
like word that speech and make my votes
I think if you've gotten the chance to
give a speech you had a chance out there
I agree I agree you were kind of the
puppet master of the season you pulled a
lot of strings behind the scenes I know
it was just crazy for me like how I will
sit every single week on that orange
couch and I think it's a key what's
going on and you're exactly like where
people were gonna vote I knew exactly
they were I mean who was gonna go home
and he was just like oh my gosh like I
know these are people watching surprised
and stuff I'm like this game is know the
heart of their home I mean like you know
I did I like I'm telling you I'm proud
of my I didn't even know I have so many
social skills like that
and
I mean like my accents really like
strong so I was just trying for dentist
on me and it worked it was cuz you know
if my only thing that killed me was no
winning competition that's it
how are you gonna face fess IDO went out
in the real world tonight cuz you called
him like my big dumb puppet yeah you
know because he was I loved his voice
all you know I love you so much
look listen I didn't betray him at all
nothing pencil just like part of my
strategy and stuff I like actually he
was I was one of the reason why I made
it so far in the game because everyone
wanted to target him so I made the other
side understand that he he was like my
connection to the other side so they
didn't turn him that much now one fence
overall crazy and start like making top
four deals with like some of the people
and stuff and talking about using me as
a pawn and stuff is like pencil is your
time to go I was there playing I knew
exactly what's going home what was going
on and that was exactly the time that
Faison needed to go you know it's not
like I want made it like talked to him
that wasn't gonna happen
how much know what happened again you
made power moves that people may be
necessary or Scott to see but people in
the house maybe didn't know exactly
exactly
now people got to watch you 24/7
everything is out there there might be a
couple things you get out today that
people go you might go oh I'm sorry for
that what do you ever say to people who
might be upset with some of your
behavior in the house I literally like I
don't even think like I 9 like I
misbehaved aback
it was all in Johnson's and and jokes
and like just living together in like
doing things and people I got I got done
so many bad things to me and I didn't
even complain or nothing I am so sorry
if anyone else that is offended I swear
that I nothing evil ever came out of my
brain and stuff even when I was trying
to strategize and backstab people and
like using and stuff I always wanted
them to have fun and feel like welcome
and feel like they were like having an
amazing time there and to love me and
feel loved by me so if anything out
there is offending anyone please do not
take it as serious like I like to be
open minded I like to understand and I
like to like express myself how I'm
feeling all the time with words I don't
like to go around the circle
so if I open anyone please I'm so sorry
please don't like throw me on honey
that's pretty much it I think you
entertained more people than you
offended so that's I hope so
all right you just got out I know but
would you go back in and play an
all-star season please and don't handle
stuff like that I don't want to like
block my opportunity stuff but you are
asking me like three hours after getting
out of there I probably it is a big guys
know that I'm going back in the house
okay you just got out of there what's
the first thing you're gonna do when
they let you out those doors tonight get
drunk all right go get drunk go Thank
You JC
[Music]